yeah once he's tired again
he's getting there
all right
let me see that rope
yeah pull them out a little bit
you ready
behind you
guys you want to jump on him
huh
yeah I'm gonna take the head
I'm gonna go to the head and you just
sit on his body
[Music]
let's keep the weight on him
give me one more
one more with for weight
and a towel to cover his eyes out
um you'll find the way you got it I just
need tape
[Music]
uh I just need something to cover his
eyes so he kills out
George is getting to town
take a strip of tape
just cover his head like behind his nose
like where my hand left hand is at
they come outside
we're going to tape
just go underneath the Rope
like right up right here
stop
all right break that off
so I'm still coming tomorrow
yeah like behind his back like you're
handcuffing
foreign
it's nice
and you're gonna do the same thing with
his back legs
[Music]
thank you
to talk a little bit all right
I want to get the Rope off
[Music]
and all the music what I do is I'll last
all the time off the telephone pole
there's nothing with the hell he wants
you're looking at the telephone pole
right there you can find out it's not a
telephone pole happening
[Music]
I'll write that one off
you got that wow
yeah that's not coming out right now
yeah you just cut it right there
no it's he's he's got his teeth in it
it's cool
just put like you good with that
one
nowhere
he's probably ten right
over here
to cover his eyes
I tell them
where are we here
[Music]
he's warming back up again